bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france à l'offensive des
talibans lancée ou lancé au mois de mai
ce qu'elle s'explique essentiellement
par l'annoncé du retrait des forces
étrangères comment est-ce que vous
expliquer cette progression si rapide
comment sinon s'était insurgé de quels
types de soutiens bénéficie-t-il
écoutez je pense qu'ils sont déjà en en
action depuis de très nombreuses années
il ne faut pas oublier quand même que
des troupes américaines et ils troupes
de l'otan ont dépassé les cent trente
mille hommes il y a six ou sept ans donc
voyez vous de ces 130 milles sommes
maintenant à 2500 et puis une
disparition il y à un continuum dans la
politique américaine qui petit à petit
se diriger vers ce retrait donc les
talibans qui était très à l'aise dans
les provinces et bien rompue
effectivement mettre à profit cet élan
nouveau et est politiquement mais
opportuniste mais ça veut dire que si ça
change complètement la situation
stratégique n'est ce pas parce que les
talibans étaient habitués à des coups de
main et et à se replier attaqué des
postes de sécurité et se replier et
c'est donc et donc petit groupe mobilité
maintenant ils tiennent des positions
c'est à dire d'une guerre de guérilla
qui l'ont menée contre une armée
régulière eh bien on est presque venu à
une armée régulière
talibane contre l'armée régulière
afghane ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une
visibilité des forces talibanes qui
n'existait pas il y a bien sûr quelques
semaines ils tiennent des villes ils
tiennent des ponts ils tiennent des
carrefours donc ils peuvent être frappés
puisqu'ils n'ont aucune puissance
aérienne donc là on est à un tournant
est ce qu'il ya une volonté politique
est ce qu'il y avait une volonté
militaire de la part des afghans et
aussi de l'allier des américains
d'intervenir dans les airs j'ai évoqué
tout cette situation dans un article que
je viens de publier sur un incident
géopolitique l'institut talleyrand donc
que voilà on est dans tunis patiente qui
va se résoudre dans les prochaines
semaines va-t-il y avoir une opportunité
de taper sur de frapper les forces
talibanes parce que maintenant elles
sont visibles en nombre les tiennent des
positions est ce qu'un gouvernement
d'union nationale est encore possible en
afghanistan où vient la prise du pouvoir
par les talibans est aujourd'hui
inévitable
d'écouté il y a d'abord une
conseil de la réconciliation nationale
donc il est à l'oeuvre il y as
deuxièmement des négociations du côté de
doha où les américains donc sont
présents avec leur envoyé spécial
zalmay khalilzad qui est d'origine
afghane d'ailleurs donc mis là une
centaine d'années il est maintenant
citoyen américain depuis 40 ans mais
donc il y à des négociations il peut y
avoir effectivement à la tentation de
dire aux talibans écoutez maintenant
voilà vous êtes pratiquement une armée
régulière donc vous pouvez subir des
désagréments de frappes aériennes on
peut on peut s'arrêter là il peut y
avoir un premier niveau de frappe il
peut y avoir un deuxième niveau de
phrases plus important donc il y à
vraiment des éléments de négociation
contre les taliban qui peuvent être donc
et efficace pour les amener
effectivement un cessez-le-feu alors on
a vu ces images afghans fuyant les
combats et les talibans est ce que c'est
dans sa grande majorité que la
population afghane rejette l'idéologie
des insurgés
écoutez je pense qu'il y avait
effectivement
différentes façons de regarder cette
situation là parce qu'il y a la
population des provinces monkey est plus
traditionnel et qui étaient sous
influence talibane donc depuis
nombreuses années et puis vous avez la
population des villes n'est ce pas qui
était beaucoup plus influencée par c'est
bien la présence occidentale avec la
fréquentation des écoles par les jeunes
femmes les jeunes filles avec donc des
emplois qui ont été créés dans la
communication dans l'institution
financière extérieure donc vous avez là
bien sûr une population qui est
infiniment plus rétive et qui risque de
se poser à la venue au pouvoir
complète des talibans on peut accepter
une participation des talibans mais je
pense que cette population des villes
sera vraiment en opposition avec un
gouvernement radical talisman
l'allemagne annoncée il ya quelques
instants qu'elle suspendait les
expulsions de migrants vers
l'afghanistan est ce que ce qui est en
jeu pour l'europe notamment c'est une
nouvelle crise migratoire à venir quel
regard est ce que vous portez sur cette
décision de berlin
écoutez je pense que effectivement un
souci mais d'abord l'afghanistan et plus
loin de nos frontières vous avez l'iran
a traversé vous avez la turquie donc
délirant accueil pratiquement un million
de réfugiés n'est ce pas donc voir il ya
des tampons si je puis dire parce que
l'europe est loin mais déjà depuis un
certain nombre de deux mois et peut-être
même deux ans on avait noté des
migrations une émigration
afghane de traversée de la manche en
allant donc vers l'angleterre qui
étaient plus nombreuses qu il y a cinq
ou dix ans donc il y a déjà vu des
préparatifs dans ce sens à d'une
émigration à des populations qui
souhaite effectivement parce qu'elles
sont la formation parce que elles
pratiquent l'anglais bien pouvoir
quitter leur pays merci beaucoup pour
votre analyse jean un vestiaire
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté